The Bookend Trust is pleased to introduce a new patron, Neil Gaiman.
Hello, I'm Neil Gaiman and I'm pleased to launch the envirothon competition for the Bookend Trust.
The award - winning author of works including Coraline, Sandman and the new Doctor Who,...
...together with his wife, multi - talented performer Amanda Palmer,...
...Neil recently visited Tasmania, and took a great interest in the wildlife...
...and environmental opportunities here.
Together they have a special message for Tasmanian students.
Tasmania is a really wonderful place and its environment and the animals are...
...part of what make it so special.
And they're all unique and fascinating and there are some things in Tasmania that don't exist anywhere else in the world.
You can have experiences and build careers working on species and places unlike anywhere else in the whole world.
So good luck to all of the students participating in...
...and watching this and future envirothons.
Make the most of this opportunity and enjoy it...
...'cause Tasmania is really special.